welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilkes your host and our guest
is not he'd seem juiced who was at Yale
as the inaugural s on your shadow fellow
in Iranian studies at the Macmillan
Center she is a cultural historian whose
work concentrates primarily on the
intersection between politics and
various modes of cultural production and
media forms in Iran and the wider Middle
East with a focus on questions of
cultural mediation political power and
social movements today we'll talk with
professor cm deuced about her book
soundtrack of the revolution the
politics of music and Iran welcome
professor thank you very much for having
me so this is very exciting I'm very
curious to hear about the music scene in
Iran so let's begin with an overview of
your book tell us about it
my book is an alternative history of
post-revolutionary Iran there was a
revolution in Iran in 1979 the royalist
Mohammad Reza Pahlavi the Shah was
deposed in a very popular uprising and
in his place became an Islamic Republic
with the revolutionary leader Ayatollah
Ruhollah Khomeini and so what my book
does is really tell the story of the
evolution of the state since then
considering this was a very radical
break for Iranian politics and history
through the use of music whether it's
the state trying to regulate and
administer music within society or they
use by the people of music in order to
relay all kinds of messages cultural
political social there was a very stark
break for music at the time of the
revolution because once Jimena took over
he was an aging cleric he actually
declared music banned he said music is
like opium for the masses if you want
your youth to be righteous eliminate
music completely so his message was very
clear and still music has very deep
roots in Iranian society and culture and
within really months the kind of music
that how many was speaking
about entered even state airwaves and so
I start the story of music's role within
society a few years before the
Revolution into the ban and how from
that point onward music really
reinterred re-entered society in a big
way and what kinds of functions it
played within within Iranian society
okay I'm curious to know what led you to
write the book I was only nine when we
left Iran at the height of at one of the
worst phases of the iran-iraq war in
1986 and I only went back about ten
years later and as a teenager and I
remember being shocked by what I saw
because when I left in 1986 this is
seven seven years into the revolution
music was a very sensitive subject and
even as a child I could tell because on
the way to holidays that the Caspian Sea
for example the grown-ups would try to
hide musical tapes there were
checkpoints you were not allowed to have
certain kinds of tapes
even though music had been green-lighted
certain kinds of it only was so March
music religious music a bit more
rhythmical but only if it was committed
to the ideals of the revolution so any
music that was you know pop music from
from prior to the revolution from the
Shahs era any rock music any western
music all of that was not allowed and so
at these checkpoints soldiers would
actually check the cars to see if there
were any musical tapes any band musical
tapes and there were fairly severe
punishments for possessing such tapes so
anywhere from fines to lashings to you
know imprisonment for for a few days and
so on and still music played such a huge
role in my life as a child in Iran
because Iran ian's love to be together
they love to celebrate music plays a
huge role there you know in any party
with even a few Iranians if there's a
certain kind of rhythm which is the 6/8
rhythm with which culturally sort of
dance inducing to Iran Ian's if you
start a song everybody will get up and
dance so still music played also such a
huge role in the private spaces of my
childhood so there was this dilemma
where the state was trying to
control the use of music and where
iranian consume it hugely within their
private spaces when I returned as a
teenager I realized that their huge
change had happened actually from the
time when I was a child I'd been a child
back in Iran my parents took me to a
restaurant at and one of these grand
hotels which before the Revolution was
called Hyatt and now was called Azadi
freedom so all these American and
Western hotels had been taken over by
the Iranian government and at the
swimming pool there was a grand piano
and there was a pianist who was actually
sitting there and playing the piano when
I was a child in Iran music and public
would have been unthinkable and so
immediately I I sensed that something
big had changed and but at the same time
he would play the music at the piano but
people knew not to clap so clapping was
still not okay because the expression of
joy in public was still problematic my
goodness yeah and so I returned to Iran
subsequently a few years later to work
as a after I've graduated from college
and got my master's I returned to work
as a journalist and again I saw huge
changes at that point in early 2000s
there were now huge pop concerts sort of
dance music almost heavily attended
thousands of people and revolutionary
Iran which at the beginning of its
tenure had banned music now not only
allowed some kind of music it actually
allowed pop music which had been
declared completely illegitimate at the
time of the Revolution because of its
associations with the promiscuous sort
of scene that it represented prior to
the revolution where the genders mix
alcohol was consumed in the cabarets of
a cosmopolitan Tehran in the 1970s so I
traced this evolution and try to
understand how it came about that
certain kinds of music eventually were
allowed and to the state now where there
dozens of concerts every month in Iran
and the state you know tries to balance
its own interests versus trying to
satisfy
a very young outward-looking globalised
population I'm curious did you track the
changes from 1979 a to a more recent
time and I'm I am very interested to
know how music kind of snuck back into
society so what happened was a few
months
first of all music had played a huge
role in the revolution success there was
a very organic production as la Mina's
production of music leading to the
revolution all these revolutionary songs
that are sort of ingrained and every
person who went through that period so
it was huge for making the revolution
actually succeed when how many band
music he was a cleric who spent his days
in contemplation and reading texts and
so on he didn't come from a background
where he understood I suppose or you
know I had lived through the context
where music can be used in context other
than cabarets and for him music really
meant that scene that's you know sha era
scene but then a a year into the few
months actually into the revolution one
of his favorite protegees Ayatollah
Murtaza Mata Hari was assassinated there
there was there a lot of square measures
sort of in the beginning years of the
revolution as as there are with most
revolutions and people trying to grab
the different political factions trying
to grab power the leftists and
nationalists the Islamists so there was
this huge assassination plot and in it
Ayatollah montessori sorry I told a
Harry passed away and some people in the
stage radio produced this song in his
commemoration and for the one year of
his commemoration they presented it to
Ho meny himself they said you know we've
made this song we know it's more
rhythmical more musical than what's
currently there on state airwaves we
just want to show it to the imam himself
and see what he thinks so how many
listened to this song and he said you
know i really would like to see the
makers of this song and the makers of
this song were brought into his presence
and he told them i don't cry much but i
cried when I heard your song it's the
most beautiful song I've ever heard and
if you can
you need to make music like this I will
support you so from that point onward
there was this notion of a committed
kind of music that that even if it was
more rhythmical even if it was more
musical and this particular piece
actually contains rhythmical sort of
passages that are very reminiscent of
some pre-revolutionary pop era classical
pop music and but from that point onward
it was understood that if the music was
used in the service of the revolution
and the ideals of the revolution it
would be it would be okay
so that was sort of the first moment
when make sort of cultural producers
realized that there was a way forward
with music and from that point onward
there were a few other important
landmark decisions and moments that led
to what we have today okay and you you
look specifically at four musicians in
your book tell us a little bit about
their work and you know how their how
their work contributes excuse me to the
culture of Iran so I look at my work is
fairly chronology chronological I look
at the first sort of the first decade of
the revolution through Iran's preeminent
vocalist of Persian classical music
mohammad reza shah jahan i then move on
to the second decade where young
musicians graduating from the music
academy the first sort of class that
graduated from the Music Academy in
post-revolutionary Iran really was
trying to make music and make it crew
make careers out of music so I look at
state-approved at this state-approved
musician ali reza as SARM and the whole
process through which the this Islamic
Iran decided pop music is okay because
it was banned for two decades and then
there was this watershed moment where
they decided we're gonna let it happen
and it was quite shocking to people who
were part of this period in
post-revolutionary around many people
believe that another I mean some people
thought a whole other revolution had
happened because all of a sudden this
pop music was there on the unstable I
was a watershed moment I mean what
the reason that they allowed it so do
you want me to tell you should I
continue with the other two musicians
before I get back to this point break it
up wherever you I'll break it up here
and then I go back at the other two
musicians who I write about in detail I
write about dozens of musicians really
in the book but there are four musicians
whose work I really highlight and so a
leaders are so what happened that
Islamic Republic decided the Islamic
Republic decided to allow for pop music
for two nearly two decades Iranians had
basically been listening to pop music
coming from Los Angeles so there was a
huge music scene in Iran at the time of
the revolution the revolution happens
how many bands music clearly this is
going to be a whole different kind of
government and a huge population of
music makers basically packs up and
moves to LA to Los Angeles and I which
is why Los Angeles is often referred to
as Tehran jealous by Iranians the
largest community of Iranian expats
outside of Iran resides in Los Angeles
and so they set up shop there and
continue producing music so for two
decades really
Iran Ian's inside Iran listened to music
coming from Los Angeles very similar to
music that was produced to produce in
pre-revolutionary Iran in the Shahs time
went underground you know in their homes
exactly since tapes would come in
through cassette tapes VHS eventually
satellite TV technology exactly so it
would be in private spaces and not in
the public and but meanwhile these young
music graduates were working on creating
their own their own music that
correspond to their realities as young
kids coming of age in the Islamic
Republic they wanted to make music their
career not for ideological reasons but
really because that's what they like to
do music for years I talked to the guy
Hacha our Hammadi for years they tried
to have the government approve their
music so how sure it's a MIDI the guy
who produce Iran's first a poster of
illusionary pop song he told me that he
went over for 3-4 years again and again
and again to state radio and television
officials and said you know put his song
his music in front of them and said
you know this is this is something I've
made can you listen to it can you can
you consider broadcasting it and over
and over again they would say no they
would write him these notes in green ink
and say no your voice there are many
problems including that his voice was
actually quite similar to the his voice
was quite similar to the voice of one of
Iran's most famous posts
pre-revolutionary pop singers Dariush so
haha it's a muddy this
post-revolutionary guy in his early 20s
who was producing this music had a role
model and this role model happened to be
a pre-revolutionary pop singer but
there's a very uncanny similarity
between their voices but ultimately what
happened and this kind of tells you that
this process was not completely top-down
as many people iranian z' actually still
believed probably they think it's a
conspiracy by the islamic republic to
produce pop music to rival the pop music
that was coming from abroad that was
part of the reasoning later on but
really what happened was these young
keith kept pushing and finally there was
an official at state television who had
the political capital in order to
approve this music he was a confidant of
ayatollah ali Harmony's the current
supreme leader the supreme leader that
took over after i had told a hominid he
was a confidant of his he also happened
to be a poet and an artist so perhaps a
softer heart and he listened to the
music and he said you know I don't see a
problem with this music I think we
should broadcast it and the the story
goes the sort of behind the scenes story
which I couldn't confirm 100% because
it's one of those you know sort of
legends that ye that you that you hear
about that you can't really 100% confirm
it goes that he spoke to Ayatollah
Khamenei Ayatollah Khamenei sought the
opinion of other clerics in macomb the
Iran seminary town and there were
discussions that look if we don't
produce our own kind of pop music these
kids will continue listening to pop
music coming in from LA why not try to
have our own pop music industry here so
it was really a push from below from
these young kids and ultimately approved
the story also highlights the importance
of
personal agency of this one guy at state
television who found who felt like he
had the capital to really take this on
and push through with this and so not
long after that this pop song was aired
on state radio and hash our item adidas
singer is the young singers own anecdote
of this of of hearing his own song for
the first time on state radio was that
he was in a taxi cab and all of sudden
his song came on and the taxi driver
just sort of you know put his foot on
the brakes and came to sort of
screeching halt and he said oh my god
things are about to change in a big way
Dhar you Sh you know this
pre-revolutionary singer is back and
he's singing on stage radio and i sure
it's Hammadi was sort of sitting in the
back seat and he said no no that's me
that's I'm I'm the one singing this song
and the driver apparently was just like
and then from that point onward from
that point onward they allowed for other
pop songs to be still aired on state
radio and today really the Islamic
Republic has resolved to allow for even
very rhythmically fast pop songs with
sometimes even risque topics you know of
singer singing about lovers who are not
interested in real love which of course
implicates that insinuates that they're
interested in you know physical love
rather than that was a red line that the
Islamic Republic officials crossed sort
of about a decade ago I would say but
the line now has been firmly drawn at
political things so ok I was ok you know
love themes even risque ones are ok no
criticism of the government but no
explicit criticism of the government but
that does not mean that musicians and
audiences don't manage through music to
actually engage in political criticism
ok and what about the other so the other
two musicians whose work I cover in
detail are Mohsen Namjoo he is a
musician who today lives in Brooklyn his
music was quite groundbreaking for the
Iranian music scene because he dared to
take Persian classical
music which was the sort of sacred art
form that had you know all kinds of
considerations as to how you perform it
in which settings the respectability of
it and so on he took it and mixed it
with blues and rock and jazz and a song
that actually got him banned from the
country even took verses from the Koran
and used them as as if they were any
other kind of text so they're you know
centuries long traditions of the
recitation of the Quran and how one does
it in what kind of person is you know
has the the stature to recite the Quran
there must be an Islamic person and so
on he took some takes from the Quran and
basically sang it with alongside with
rock and blues and that finally got him
into to receive a prison sentence of
five years and he happened to be outside
of Iran at the time when this happened
and so has never returned but his music
because of the use of fusion of all
different modes of music and also his at
the time very critical lyrics was quite
groundbreaking for the Iranian scene in
the mid to that sort of late 2000s the
fourth art as artists whose musician
whose work I cover in detail is Susheela
Carrie also known as hitch gasps The
Godfather of Persian hip-hop he was
instrumental in in in getting a hip-hop
scene going in Iran and he's one of the
most popular rappers in Iran although
there there have their husband now been
a whole new generation after him but his
his music is his whole mode of his
discourse is very different from Nam
Jews the the alternative in wasn't a
fusion
so Mohsen Namjoo is now in his early 40s
he came about he came of age at a time
when they're they're still very strict
restrictions on people's private public
and also private lives where you know
you couldn't for example have long hair
as a man or wear short sleeves or this
is you know in the first two decades of
the revolution it was still a very
severe sort of public policing of
people's lives and bodies and so his his
music and his than kinds of things that
he sings about are very he's basically
in a conversation with that upbringing
and the state and rebelling against that
and the kinds of strictures that were
put on him hich Cass comes of age a
couple of about a decade later he does
not remember the revolution or the
eight-year war with Iraq which was a
very difficult moment for most Iranians
he came of age at a time when george w
bush had taken over 9/11 happened iran
was declared part of the axis of evil
and these young kids coming of age in
iran really they're they they had more
of a you know sort of fight to pick with
having been being subjugated to that
kind of discourse where they are part of
this axis of evil and the unequal power
global how relations in the world where
america gets to attack and invade
Afghanistan and Iraq and so it's a whole
different kind of discourse he's not
really in conversation with the state he
is rivaling this state which is why his
music is I think so pertinent and so
popular within among young Iranians
because he presents this other kind of
yeah I mean by by putting one of his
songs for example is called a bunch of
soldiers and in it he says you know the
streets are the biggest universities me
and my Posse we are the soldiers of Iran
we hold up the flag so implicitly he's
really passing this message that the
Iranian state is no longer fit to hold
up Iran's honor
it's his discourse is based on this old
Iranian honor code where Iranians have
to stand up to protect their honor and
to stand up for what they believe in
because the state is no longer capable
of doing that and once the 2009 green
uprising happened he produced a song in
which there's some implicit critique
enough that he was questioned several
times and ultimately decided to leave
the country and what do you think the
future holds for the music scene and
and how do you think the mute the music
will identify Iran in the in the coming
years
so I think the one of the most
interesting musicians whose work I look
at is the vocal the vocalist of Persian
classical music Mohammed Azharuddin he's
an icon for Iranians and he's been
singing he's now 77 years old he's been
singing for many decades prior to the
revolution after the Revolution and
through his music you really see sort of
the long arc of Iranian politics and
there's that saying you know the long
arc of the moral universe and the moral
the arc of the moral universe is long
and it bends toward justice I think you
can apply that to the Iranian scene and
say the arc of Iranian politics is long
and it bends toward democracy and
freedom and you really see that and when
we think about underground music or
political music in the Iranian context
we always think about rock music and rap
music and so on but I would argue that
and I do argue in the book that his
music is the most pertinent because it
connects back to a time about a century
ago when Iranians had an uprising in a
revolution for a constitution in 1906
take some of those songs that were
composed back then and really in his
through his concerts and through his
music is able to draw this long arc and
audiences engage with him in very
passionate ways and call forth on him to
sing this song the morning bird in which
the Caged Bird is called upon to break
free from the cage and sing of freedom
and so on and I think when you look at
Iranian music you see that you see
there's there's a and not just in the
you know rock and rap and whether you
really see it in the more classical
music even more so that is deeply
ingrained in Iranian families and of all
backgrounds you do see that there's this
diverse message and presented in
different genres and modes and so on but
that ultimately the music that matters
the music that people really care about
this message of freedom and greater
rights and the word democracy is a
little tainted and complicated but the
kinds of things that Iranian society
aspired to and I believe the music
points to you know some something
hopeful do you think it will ever get
back to pre 1979 where they had
basically full freedom to express
themselves as they would like so that is
a misunderstanding actually prior to
1979 you know it was a different kind of
a in fact one must say that there's been
much greater democracy in
post-revolutionary Iran in
pre-revolutionary Iran so prior to the
Revolution it was a royal dictatorship
there was basically there were simply no
political parties at the political party
that existed was the Shahs political
party but following the Revolution there
have been actual elections and so it's
complicated because politically people
have many more rights and since the
Revolution but of course it's an Islamic
Republic with its own Islamic ideals and
so in terms of personal freedoms and
also political freedoms I'm not saying
there's like full political freedom but
compared to part you know prior to the
revolution there they're certainly more
political freedoms so I don't think most
people would want it to go back to the
time before the Revolution I'm just just
in terms of the music itself was there
more freedom in the music prior to 1979
no people would have gotten into trouble
for stating political sort of okay ins
back then yeah that's good to understand
so what do you conclude in your book so
I conclude that music has been this
incredible space where despite the given
restrictions heroic musicians and their
corresponding audiences have managed to
carve out the space to allow for
conversations to happen that would not
be happening in the pub in the open
public sphere pushing on all kinds of
topics the Internet of course has been
super helpful as well and allowing for
this kind of music to circulate prior to
the internet it had to happen in
concerts and it was a bit more
it was less explicit but since the
Internet people being able to access any
kind of music these messages can be
related more openly and people can
consume them more easily
so music really offers this very
significant political space that is
quite understudied still that's one of
the conclusions of the book the other
conclusion of the book is really about
how the Islamic Republic has functioned
as a state in terms of its policy making
in social and cultural areas and there
the conclusion is that the Islamic
Republic has been quite adept at trying
to find ways of responding to some of
the needs of the population but very
clear on the red lines and drawing them
at at its political sort of sort of
borders right this has been fascinating
thank you so much for being here today
thank you so much for having me for more
information about professor cm juste and
her research please visit our website at
macmillan report yale.edu be sure to
join us again for another episode of the
Macmillan report made possible through
funding from the Whitney and Betty
Macmillan Center for International and
area studies at Yale
you